wow sounds
[Music]
wet okay good girl Hello everybody we're
the rose nice to meet you my name is w
and I Amun I'm I'm we're here with
BuzzFeed to read some thirsty ass tweets
yay
Thursday I need the rose reading thst
tweets content for purpose of an
academic research what do you mean by
that they learn about us great let's get
started why is the Rose woong so hot
like who told him to be like that
doesn't seem as thirsty as I thought it
would be so I don't know what to say I
mean they're being mild thank you Mom
and Dad for creating me so mild okay oh
dojun please cuddle me we could both use
it oh why does she feel like you need a
cuddle I mean cuddle it's very easy I
can do it every time 24/7 really with
anyone I love cuddling but uh we could
both use it h
okay can someone ask hajun if he could
crack my back for me wow thanks crack my
back like this crack oh crack maybe it
has meaning that we don't understand
even more how do you crack your back
like no no no no no not like that me the
entire concert starting at Tong's
massive smile I bet I could fit in there
is it Thursday our fans are very
yeah very
very can someone print me a poster of
woo song all
wet it's like I may need it on my wall
oh I do have them I mean what no no no
no no not in my room in my phone I have
those pictures not in my room your War
you could actually print it yourself I
mean I shot a music video like that all
wet oh yeah Dad shirtless and everything
please print it out out have it on your
wall do what you need to
do I root for you put hatun like please
hit me over the head with his
drumsticks please and thank you stroke
your head stroke your head that sounds
weird not stroke is H maybe you like a
little simulation by hitting by we
understand Tong's so fine I can't see if
the man so hot he was just sitting there
but I went photo f what's this ravely
hung like an animal
oh cool
cool do more of that oh look at me I'm
Kim Wang I have pretty eyes and a cute
cheeky smile and a lovely husky voice
and cheekbones that could cut diamonds
Le go
yourself okay well I might go do that
myself uh right now right now really
okay I'll wait until this is over okay
can I have an appointment with sir part
Jun I need him to step on me I can do
more than that I can do more than that
let's start stepping on you yes hon from
the rose has great thighs what is
thighs oh this is fat no sexy the rose
more like the visuals I'm screaming all
of them are goodlooking man but I have
to say is Chong for
me boy looks could kill commit murder
does this h s h d h d h HS f mean
something Haun Sami hajun tun hajun tun
hajun Sami you
Fu Hannah that's my mom's
name this is this is weird W song could
spank me any time oh my God I don't know
I mean I would have had a different
comment about that one but that's my
mom's name so what a coincidence yeah I
don't know how I should take that my mom
was usually spanking me when I was was
younger it's just getting weird some
spank me anytime sure where are you come
over here okay now looks so good like
bro that jawline could cut my finger
there you
are yeah I Haun seduce my mom maybe your
dad seduced your mom yeah I'm sure he
did sure he did so he's saying he
doesn't seduce people that has a
significant other good call Jon's Joe is
soing sharp it could slice me in half
and I wouldn't even
complain am I so
sharp I don't know you keep saying it's
so sharp I don't know seems pretty soft
to me I want to have sex with Wong's
voice so bad so bad
oh finally so did I just whisper so bad
so bad I think it's singing My Heart
C that's the only way
stop
moving I don't know if I want to
with my voice it just seems like I
wouldn't get any pleasure out of it yes
you can me just yeah Whispering yeah
because if you whisper they will react
and by looking at their reaction you can
get something something what your
imagination dojun and his oozing sex
appeal okay oozing it sounds wet can
Jong slip my throat with his Jae line
I'm telling you it's not
slit your throat come
here but how can you do this slit my
throat with this jaw line
like okay can you imagine J doing that
to somebody I don't want to can you put
your head up I'm going to Slit your
throat with my jawline wow this is
another one
from who song stop summoning my inner
please oh right good
job okay good girl okay I miss my thick
ddy doing twoes two that means you're
like extra thick you're like thick okay
well I can be whoever just tell me oh
really whatever you want okay thick Doon
okay Officer I'm reporting hon for
making me horny oh be yeah with your
thighs sexist things about Jong aren't
even his hand veins or his long fingers
or his neck or his lips the sexy thing
about him is that he's the ultimate bias
wrecker nobody's ever qualified to wreck
you but Jong by well F I see that you
have my photo on your Twitter so I'm
guessing I'm your bias and he's your
bias recer recer in that case I don't
want to be your bias anymore ooh
territorial it's okay I'm your new
bias oh hand
PS
okay I think it was pretty mild I
thought you know our fans would go a
little bit more crazier maybe it's our
first time doing this so they wanted to
take it very slow we could take it slow
I mean we're all grown right you guys
should know that we are 30 30 30 thirsty
thirst but I mean uh thank you so much
for sending those Tweets in it was very
cute um we by the way yes we do have an
album that has came out uh it's called
go and check it out uh and let's see you
on our show and always we Rose you thank
you
[Music]
buzz